he's Tom Tolbert Bay Area talk-show host
he is the talk-show host in the Bay Area
former Warriors radio color analyst and
former NBA player spent I think seven
years in the Association and Tom joins
us now
good morning Tom how's morale uh mine
mine fantastic I feel really good you
know got up early thanks to you a
usually don't get up this early in there
the weather is good I never get some
exercise then so yeah I feel great
how do you think the Warriors feel today
oh oh that's what you meant you know
yeah probably not great you know you win
the game you're happier force a game six
but you know you're trying to get one of
your teammates back and then he goes
down and now he's out for the rest of
the series and may be out for all next
year who knows what the extent of the
injury is so yeah I think stuff said it
the best last night after the game mixed
emotions on the last night at night they
should be super pumped about
they're pretty pumped about right
afterward and then I'm mature and and
after that wore off then it was a
feeling for their teammate Kevin Durant
would he put would he put his body
through to get to this point and then to
have it kind of collapse on him again
it's just a bummer
what questions do you have about this
whole situation with Durant the medical
staff you got Bob Meyers in the front
office saying if you want to blame
somebody blame him what do you want to
know that we don't know about this
Durant situation you know what I think
is is a it's a former athlete I don't
really I don't really care I think other
people care a lot about who's to blame
and I think it's a society we always
want to figure out who goes to blame but
you know sometimes things happen
sometimes you do though other all the
right things and then it doesn't turn
out the way you want to turn out
sometimes the body doesn't respond the
way you want it to to respond you know
you could look at MRIs and say okay
you're good to go you can go through all
the training and and all the build-up
and the practice and and you feel good
and then all of a sudden you reinjure it
if that never happened there
a word reinjure so I just I don't blame
anybody uh I don't know that anybody
look I know a lot of people in that
organization I find it highly unlikely
that anybody pressured this guy to play
I find it I find it plausible that an
athlete would want to get back and play
and say you know what I'm gonna give it
a go this is Game five of the NBA Finals
and I want to play I want to get out
there
athletes have been known to push
themselves they that's that's what they
do they want to play and this is the
biggest stage to play on so I can
believe that but do you think believe
that if Golden State was up three games
to one do you think Kevin Durant place
Dan I don't know I don't know how is
thang I mean he practiced I don't know
how he felt I don't know how the calf
responded to it so that that I don't
know it's plausible yeah it's plausible
to say hey we're up through one let's go
ahead and give it another game or
another two days but I also think it's
very plausible to assume hey this was
the time this is where everything came
together this is where the doctor said
he's good this is where you know Bob and
Steve and Webber isn't on the decision
making along with Kevin said you know
what this is the right time I feel good
let's go ahead and do this and it's also
plausible to think all that happened and
then he still got Rangers did you at any
point in your college career when you're
at Arizona and you got you know a great
team you got Shawn Elliott and judge
Buller and Steve Kerr did you ever look
around and go that Steve Kerr one day is
gonna be one of the great NBA coaches I
don't know if anybody ever thinks that
for head but I knew he'd be a coach that
was yeah that was pretty clear I mean he
was a leader on that team there wasn't
even wasn't even a question some guys
just know how to lead men some guys
don't and some guys can maybe you know
they can kind of kind of build their way
into it I just always knew with him our
junior year we had a pretty good team
too but he I heard that summer before in
the world champion
yes I want to say I know he blew his
knee out I think it was against Russia
but not positive and that's a new that's
what we were missing that year we got
beat in the first round by by UTEP a
funny thing my my my former teammate and
my future teammate of that game Timmy
Hardaway was on that team he definitely
beat us yeah they beat us in Tucson for
crying I think those I think I was the
last time they're loud they a team to
play on its home court in the NCAA
tournament which was pretty stupid we
were like a ten see there were seven and
we're at home they still beat us but I
knew that year I was like God we're just
we need that guy and he was that guy and
I knew I knew it'd always be successful
doing whatever he was going to do in
life I had figured he'd be a coach I
didn't thank me how could I predict that
he'd win you know championships but good
grief I mean isn't enough enough I mean
rings just follow this guy around
it's incredible how many does he have
ring just ease the gate I think he has
eight five as a player I believe it they
get three with the Bulls two with the
Spurs and three with the Warriors eight
rings this guy has incredible man and
he's gonna be a hall-of-famer
right I mean no I mean this guy's
already got a big enough head alright
last night let's not go there just way
yeah well he's gonna I have to talk to
this regular faces I'm not I'm not ready
to call hall-of-famer Steve Kerr yeah
you don't know I probably never will
okay how does this play out game six
I you know what it's an incredible win
by the Warriors and I put nothing past
them and they showed it last night I
think Steph said it best the postgame
press so we got nothing to prove to
anybody anymore about our mettle and our
toughness and and what we stand for and
how we play the game that those
questions have been those questions have
been answered and last night was an
incredible victory but I mean they they
made twenty threes and they won the game
by one point and Toronto didn't shoot a
lick last night Danny Green did nothing
from a shooting standpoint Lowry got
lay Leonard scored it wasn't efficient
in scoring see I could even put less
nine minutes of the game I have no idea
that Adam I don't know if he just wasn't
in it if if nurse rather would rather
have Kyle out there for defense I had to
go back and rewatch that let it hit me
it's the Aukerman play the last nine
minutes of that basketball game it was
it was bizarre but Toronto had a last
shot at it
which was interesting I went back and
watch that again - and that was just a
weird play because I didn't love the big
adalat double team I thought he came at
him right when he was looking at him and
usually when players are looking at you
and they see the double-team coming
they'll pick you apart but he had Lowry
and Gasol I don't know what they were
doing I have no clue what they were
doing I mean then Lowry ran away from
the play
so Iguodala comes double-team and as I
was trying to set a back pick her by
doing something on the other side of the
court and nobody makes themselves
available right under the bucket when so
many double teams somebody cuts makes
themselves available and you find an
open player they just I mean they just
butchered that play all the help that
being said at one of those guys will
probably shoot the ball better in Game
six and or Game seven but if the words
won Game six
look the words have been there before
they've done this before they know what
it takes the Raptors don't know what it
takes before and nerves could creep in
so I put it this way I'd make the
Raptors certainly the favorites
obviously they got two games to win one
but don't count out the team that's been
to the fourth straight finals Tom good
to talk to you I hope things are well we
appreciate your time as always
at Somme Tolbert bay area talk show host
former warriors radio color analyst and
former NBA player if you missed any of
the interviews from the mercedes-amg man
cave go to the Dan Patrick show app you
can watch and listen
inside mercedes-amg man cave
mercedes-amg driving performance for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]